[Applaudissements]
non sanex
allez c'est parti c'est le willy allô
allô allô oui voilà séquence ouvry oui
allô willy oui bonjour vous dit ça va
c'est daniel tu te souviens tu peux rien
c'est daniel tu te souviens de moi
daniel monio daniel moi qu'à liège
moreau whip it and non salées du tout
non voilà là je vois jeu j'avais une
question juste comme ça qui me venait ce
matin vous on se connaît tous ben je
croyais que vous vous souvenez de moi
alors je la mets pas ce que parce qu'en
fait j'ai cru que c'était non je me suis
trompé mais j'ai quand même une question
essentielle est ce que vous l'avez vu ce
matin qui
[Rires]
nadel ses keynotes patron sur france 2
ris parce que j'ai créé ça j'ai reconnu
sa voix un moment c'est william
leymergie
[Applaudissements]